what do a lipstick a microwave and car
paint have in common a better question
quote You by surprise well should you
want to analyze the manufacturing
process of each of these products you'll
find that in all three cases Mica is
used Mica from the Latin word Mikko I
shine is a very special group of
minerals in fact there are easy and
perfect flaking even by simple rubbing
with fingers splits them into very thin
but elastic and flexible foils and
scales with a characteristic mother of
pearl luster their versatility of use is
remarkable in addition to the
possibility of being combined with other
layers of material they can be ground
and used in the form of powders or
flakes and possess a natural low
electrical and thermal conductivity
because of these properties it's
possible to find their use in most
Cosmetics on the market such as
eyeshadows and Foundations but also in
making paints oven Windows heating
systems and even toothpastes of course
just as without other minerals Mica must
be sorted mined and processed before
it's placed on the market for sale if
you have never heard of them maybe I can
also explain why according to the
observatory of economic complexity at
The Institute of Technology in Cambridge
Massachusetts in 2021 the market for
micas had a total commercial value of
237 million dollars in purely economic
terms these minerals participate in only
0.00011 percent of the global market a
trifle in practice when put in relation
to their variety of uses the country
that exported the largest amount in
monetary terms was China with a total of
61 million dollars this was followed by
the Netherlands India Madagascar and
France in terms of imports however the
main buyers turn out to be Japan China
Germany the United States and Belgium
until a few years ago the use of mica
and cosmetic products was a source of
Pride for the major multinationals in
the sector because these are elements
that are already present in nature and
therefore not to synthesize their
Laboratories which allows them to add
the natural stamp to their makeup of
choice this was as I said until a few
years ago today I want to focus on two
of the Nations I just mentioned India
and Madagascar similar to what happens
in other so-called underdeveloped or
developing countries the logic of profit
involves costs Beyond those in money I
am talking in this case about the
exploitation of Labor which
unfortunately also and especially
concerns children and to talk about it I
have referred to two investigations
centered on service interviews and field
observations supported by statistics
regarding the volume of domestic micro
trades but we'll get to that slowly
let's start with India in 2016 a Thomson
Reuters Foundation survey conducted over
three months in the Indian states of
Bihar jharkhand Rajasthan and Andhra
Pradesh shed light on a widespread the
reality of child labor in so-called
ghost Minds the main type mind in India
is moscowite also known as white or
common Mica which although it can be
used as an insulating material is also
used to give shine to makeup and skin
care products according to information
extracted from the Zaba platform which
catalogs data regarding Indian import
export they are exported more than 100
000 tons of mica in 2015. for the Indian
Bureau of mines on the other hand the
whole of India would have produced about
20 000 in the same year according to
Reuters these huge discrepancy is
explained by the fact that 70 percent of
production depending on the legal mining
of mica conducted mostly in abandoned
forests and quarries and here we come to
the darker side of ghost mining the
tender age of the victims involved in
fact according to reports by the
children's rights advocacy Association
bachpan Bashaw andolan in June 2016
alone 20 children died in the mica mines
double the monthly average in fact
widespread health risks related to the
lack of proper Safety Systems and
continuous exposure to dust include the
respiratory problems skin infections and
deep Cuts this happens because in most
cases children are forced to collect the
mica with their bare hands and although
these minerals aren't harmful the
environment from which they are
extracted can be unlike adults moreover
children can enter deeper cavities and
so more easily prone to collapse where
they get to spend up to 8 hours and they
do it for a miserable pay we are talking
about between 50 and 300 rupees or
between 80 cents and 4 dollars a day
since in 90 percent of cases these
deaths Gora reported to local
authorities the actual deaths could be
far higher than those reported I didn't
know how dangerous the work in the mines
is had I known I would never have let
him go farmer was developeratop father
of a 16 year old boy who died in June in
2016 in jharkhand told the Reuters they
said it took almost a day to dig out his
body after the money collapsed they
cremated him without telling me Pratap
then reveals that he accepted the
payment of 100 000 Indian rupees equal
to 1 500 he did this in exchange for his
silence to avoid ending illegal mining
on protected Forest lands that bring
income to some of India's poor rest
areas by protected Forest land the
Reuters refers to the forest
conservation Act passed by India's
parliament in 1980 a directive that
resulted in a drastic reduction in
mining and in the specific case of mica
led to a reduction in the 730 licensed
quarries operating in 1964 to a maximum
of 148 still active in 1986 and in 2014
the Indian Bureau of Mines reported only
two Mica mining licenses in the entire
state of Bihar Which is far from the
reality of the situation as early as
1993 Sanjay Kumar had documented in his
book problems and Prospects of mineral
industry in India the existence of
widespread illegal Minds especially in
the Bihar Mica belt that although
abandoned and lacking Machinery were
still being exploited to sell the
mineral to those who demanded it it's
possible to assume that unlicensed
quarries hidden in dense forests
proliferated to meet the constant
domestic and international demand for
Mica to understand the phenomenon of
ghost mining we need to dig deeper
Reuters investigation is intertwined
with an interesting March 2016 report
titled the Beauty and the Beast it was
published by the network of
international organizations thirdezome
which fights against the child
exploitation and discrimination in
collaboration with the SoMo an
independent Dutch Research Center
investigating a multinational
corporations according to the data
collected in the year
2015-2016 underage workers amounted to
about 20 000 scattered in more than 300
villages in the state of jharkhand alone
page 21 of the document lays out the
percentages of the population residing
in the states of jharkhand and Bihar
leaving below the poverty line their
literacy level and the level of
Education of children and teenagers
between the ages of 6 and 14. it
immediately jumps out that these are
much worse data than the Indian average
which might suggest a link to child
labor it's likely in fact that children
find themselves working to make up a
bite with little pocket money for the
economic condition of their families to
the detriment of their education
tardeson also refers to another problem
endemic of the India reality castes
according to a 2011 census referring to
the sub-districts of the two Federated
States of Bihar and the jharkhand in the
largest of them namely rajaoli gawan and
Dom change the percentages of dalits the
so-called Untouchables or individuals of
the lowest social status belonging to
groups placed outside the pattern of the
for traditional castes are 29 16 and 14
percent of the total population
respectively if this reality is still so
widespread despite the formal ovulation
of untouchability and the Discrimination
that comes with it what are the Indian
government and the multinational
corporations that import products from
India doing to counter it in January
2017 some 20 companies into the
cosmetics and electronics Industries set
up the responsible Mica initiative aimed
at funding educational and social
projects to remove not only children but
also families from working in the mines
to date more than 80 multinational
companies join including Chanel L'Oreal
Merck and Shiseido criticism however
hasn't been slowing coming first it's
worth noting that Beauty and the Beast
clearly mentions in chapters 7 and 8 the
major companies involved in the mica
Market although thirdezon and SoMo don't
link them directly to child labor they
accuse them of supporting its purpose
situation by continuing to buy minerals
from India it's not hard to imagine that
this same company is in anticipation of
enormous image damage have Run for Cover
for example pigment company konkai the
largest importer of mica from jharkhand
and Bihar in the first half of 2015 with
the 6200 tons worth 201 million Indian
rupees immediately stated it would help
a terdazon saved 10 000 children the
jharkhand government also followed suit
promising to legalize the mines to also
regularize work activities within them
unfortunately however it seems that
nowadays the situation hasn't changed at
all the pandemic hasn't only worsened
the conditions of those living in
contact with mines but has created a
vacuum in terms of information on the
issue in 2021 the Thomson Reuters
Foundation again called out
multinational Cosmetics companies the
reason was that the funds allocated to
the responsible Mica initiative about a
million dollars a year wouldn't be used
to combat child labor since children
would seem to continue to report
infections and be victims of accidents
of various kinds then there is another
problem on the horizon there has been
criticism of the word of makeup yet the
electronics Industry has no less impact
on the global mica's market to realize
this let's knows which hemisphere and
move to a country that is in worse shape
than the Indian Federated States
Madagascar we are talking about
according to World Bank data about a
purely agricultural nation that has a
poverty rate of 80 percent this
percentage of the population in fact
lives on little more than two dollars a
day according to the world food program
food insecurity Madagascar also worsened
by frequent environmental disasters
involves about 9 million people out of
28 total if we admit the existence of a
correlation between poverty and the
child labor what am I about to say will
not surprise you in 2018 according to
unichev 47 percent of malagasy children
between the ages of 5 5 and 17 were
employed as labor force this reality is
even more daunting in the south of the
country which has been plagued for
nearly four decades but the anti-state
violence of so-called dahalo Bandits the
cattle Riders according to Amnesty
International some 4 000 people
including thieves civilians security
forces and soldiers died between 2015
and 2019 as a result of the government's
hard response to the dahalo the raids
and repression continue to this day to
claim victims it's precisely in this
context that most of the mica mining
activities in which children are
involved are concentrated in this Regard
in 2019 and three years after Beauty and
the Beast thirdezome and SoMo released a
new report it found the presence of
malagazi territory of 201 deposits of
flogobite a mica that is used in the
manufacture of electrical and thermal
insulators 176 of which would be located
in the southern regions of
the data strongly clashes with that
reported by The Bureau de catastrominier
de Madagascar which as of July 2019
recorded 50 valid concessions for Mica
mining or a quarter of the mines
actually exploited how is this possible
on page 23 the paper lays out what the
supply chain for Mica is in Madagascar
about 20 000 miners are involved in
extracting the required minerals which
are then acquired by 400 buyers
including Independents and employees of
multinational companies operating in the
territory then is the turn of the
Transporters who take the micas to five
companies that are responsible for
sorting and dividing them one of this is
3H whose complex is located in tolagnaro
the capital of the anosi region it takes
six hours of driving on narrow unpaved
roads to reach the plant by truck
finally goods are piled up at Porte
holla built in 2009 by the malagasy
government and used as a docking port
for cruise ships cargo ship and rivers
compared to Mica mined in India in
Madagascar's case this mineral goes to
meet the needs of different sectors and
apparently has only one interlocutor in
2017 about 19 percent of the mica mined
in Madagascar was exported by C2 China
where it was used as a component to
produce wires to cables and household
appliances as well as finding use in the
automotive industry instead the zombie
shows on page 52 of its report the four
main multinational corporations
importing Madagascar's Mica are Chinese
and engaged in the construction
high-tech and electronics sectors and
would buy the mineral for a very small
sum around 4 cents per kilo now we come
to the sourest note the trait that
unites India and Madagascar in the
circuit-centered on labor exploitation
of the twenty thousand malagasi miners
at least 10 000 are between the ages of
5 and 17. thirdezome has reported cases
of very young miners who are only fed at
night because they are constantly busy
during the day suffering frequent back
and headaches from too many hours spent
in uncomfortable positions and oxygen
deprivation inside the tunnels in 2019
NBC conducted an investigation on
malagasy soil following in the footsteps
of terradasone and quietly without
announcing its arrival arriving in
ambosari South 70 kilometers west of
tolagnaro reporters took photos of women
and children intent on sorting nearby
mind micas the mothers interviewed
confessed to earning the equivalent of
three dollars a week working for 13
hours a day at the time NBC asked for an
interview with 3H whose manager
hajaranahari said he was aware of child
labor in the mica mines adding however
that is not our problem it's not our
fault but the parents of the children if
it wasn't for the Micah all these people
would be Bandits and right now they
would be stealing cars data exposed by
thirdezome however say that in the
southern region of Madagascar only 12
percent of children finish secondary
school and just 25 percent of the
population has access to clean water
maybe just maybe it's the state that is
lacking and it's the companies that are
profiting from it the multinational
surveyed including Japan's Panasonic
America's electroc and China's crrc said
they were unaware of the reality of
child labor and would investigate their
own Supply chains the fact remains that
widespread monitoring is very difficult
in part because the Confluence of some
of the mic extracted by malagasy
children within the flow of mica from
India makes it virtually impossible to
identify the products into which it goes
and when we consider that many other
companies including Ford Fiat isovolta
and Boeing rely on Mica sheets to make
their cars and airplanes the plot
thickens obviously I don't have a
solution to the problem nor am I here to
tell you to stop buying an eyeshadow or
a car unfortunately although critical
for its insulating properties and
resistance to high voltage Mica is still
a niche market on which not much of a
spotlight is shining in short it's hard
to see what goes where as I anticipated
several companies such as L'Oreal
haven't given up on Mica in favor of
synthetics continuing to purchase it
only through a transparent and traceable
supply chain in order to promote
Economic Development and improve the
living conditions of Indian workers
Britain's Lush on the other hand had
already shown its intention in 2014 to
remove all traces of so-called natural
Mica from its products because of its
connection to child labor and as of 2018
has reached to making synthetic Mica
well I'm done here for today the
intention was to draw attention to a
problem that exists and is very little
talked about so I hope despite the
amount of data that I've managed to
offer you a fairly clear and
comprehensive analysis thank you all for
your attention and we'll see you in the
next video ciao